this is a very exciting day let me
explain what's happening
uh right now
uh myself
uh matt gorley and sona
are broadcasting for the very first time
in our new podcast space
it's beautiful and this is has been a
dream of mine for quite a while
uh as many of you know this podcast
started how long ago was about
over three years ago three years ago
over three years ago
we started the podcast and at the time
it was pre-coveted a year pre-covered i
think we started doing the podcast uh i
was still doing my television show out
of warner brothers studio we started
doing the podcast and we just built
we just seized a room wasn't it the
band's dressing it was the band's old
dressing room we kicked them out and
said uh you'll perform nude from now on
and um so we started broadcasting from
there it wasn't properly soundproofed
we were just having fun goofing around
we we didn't anticipate this podcast
becoming anything
more than just a fun distraction uh for
ourselves even though
things have gone gangbusters we were in
the warner brothers space for a while it
was comical because i would be talking
to
really big guests
you know some big stars would come in to
talk
and they'd be telling uh incredible
heartbreaking stories
and you'd hear trucks backing up
because all that happens on the warner
brothers lots is trucks drive in they
don't even have anything in them and
then they all throw that into reverse
[Music]
we did that for a while then kovit came
along
of course we went to zoom
then after kovitz started to loosen up a
little bit we were out of the earwolf
studios but we never had a home we've
always been wandering around
nomadically looking for a place to land
about a year ago i decided i want a home
i want a home where
if i'm pee-wee i want this to be
pee-wee's play house i i need a place
where i can hang out
waste people's time
writers can gather
we can start working on all these fun
projects
and we can do our podcast
so we went on a search we found this
building and adam says it's about a year
ago we purchased this building
and they've been working on it
and they just said it's it's done
come on in
and it's
great it's really nice
it's so nice i'm i feel nervous i've
said earlier i don't know if i could
talk about dicks in here it's just too
nice
you can talk about dicks anywhere the
table and console are shaped like a dick
that
is i know but i just feel like it's so
nice i have my hands clasped on my lap
and i'm like you will quickly forget
okay and i know you sona i've seen you
i i've been to uh all these fancy places
with you all around the world
we've been to
embassies we've been to cathedrals the
white house we've been to the white
house you always find a way to talk
about dicks so i'm not worried about
that that's impressive yeah it's amazing
it is my gift you're right it is uh one
of many gifts yes thank you no wait no v
gift
the whole team has been working very and
and i cannot tell you i'm like a kid in
a candy store
and i know um
kovid you know there's has been this
very disruptive period for everybody all
around the world and i never knew how
much i needed to be
in a space as you know i grew up in a
big family and we were all crammed in
together and that's what i like and
um i like having my people around me and
we have not had that and so i don't know
i almost practically got emotional when
i walked it was my birthday just
coincidentally yeah but it was my
birthday when they finally let us come
in here
just total
people said what are you doing today and
i said i
i think i just got myself a building
for my birthday
it's like the most entitled thing in the
world you know it's not it's cool no no
it's not it's your offices it's a really
cool space i feel like it's a place
people would want to come to do work
like i would actually want to come here
and work yeah this is sona what happened
to you i don't know
i don't know
well
and no it really is and and and you were
kind of stunned weren't i was blown away
this is the nicest podcast studio i've
ever been in and i've recorded podcasts
in some of the finest closets in houses
of people
but this is gorgeous and it's so
state of the art this is well not table
shaped like a big smells good we were
smelling it also you know what's uh you
know what's fascinating is um they have
really good
cameras now yeah in here and so we went
from not having cameras
to having basically uh 7-eleven security
cameras
so we tied up four ring doorbell cameras
yeah so i'd be talking to president
barack obama and it it literally did
look like two guys in a in a weed deal
gone bad an alley
that the police were reviewing that's
what it looked like and uh more so
because uh well he tried to buy weed
from me that's what yeah that's what
happened i said hey i'm not holding i'm
you yeah
you've got narc written all over you i
know are you kidding me
last person
no no the president the president was
where president obama was wearing a wire
at the time
so coming would you um
like to purchase uh some uh some
marijuana
you're obama
i'll do it better
so conan would you uh maybe enjoy some
marijuana is that it that's good better
it's getting better no is it getting
better or worse
it's clipped he's very clipped i'm not i
don't do impressions but he's very
clipped yeah yeah would you maybe like
to purchase some marijuana
that's norm mcdonald kind of no nor
mcdonald's more like uh
i bought a farm
you bought a farm norm yeah yeah
i got three daughters
i tried traveling salesman came by um oh
wow all right i won't do impressions
anymore um they're good that was good
it's it's just nice it's so nice to be
here and i can feel the creative juices
starting to feel verbal because there's
a lot i want to do
because people have been asking me since
i it's not just the podcast but people
been asking me like what's what's coming
and i've known
that i want to be
making stuff and
putting stuff out there
but first things first we need to have
this
place we need to have this
weird clubhouse where we can get
together and have
lots of terrible ideas and then
occasionally a good one and
that should be the name of my production
company
lots of bad ideas and occasionally a
good one
uh
and um so i'm just i'm
couldn't be happier that's pure joy
you're hearing in my voice
and yeah that's about as good as it gets
congrats yeah this is a big deal and
congrats yeah it's very cool that you
have this space and yeah i'm very happy
and so grateful to everybody that made
this happen and uh and it's only going
to start to look and sound better and on
the birthday we got you a building yeah
i know thank you matt and i bought it
for you there's giant candles on the
roof that you have to go blow out
just torches yeah yeah it's going to
make next year's birthday really hard to
talk looking at the queen man last year
i got a bill we're going to buy the
queen mary yeah you know they're trying
to get rid of it what yeah no yeah they
want to sink it at one point they were
going to sync it no they're not wait a
minute yes we should move this building
and put it in the queen mary then we can
drive around on the high seas where
there are no fcc laws yes and do
whatever we want yes
yes that's what we're going to do this
building that we just got would fit
inside the queen mary this will be the
bridge the new i can't wait to see how
this meeting goes at the bank
now what is it you want to do mr o'brien
you know i just i i got this uh kind of
small town house uh in in los angeles oh
yes we know we handled the loan right
what i like to do is move that into the
queen mary and purchase the queen mary
oh we have a loan for that yes yeah well
that sounds sound to me pre-approved
and then i want to sail around the world
in the dilapidated queen mary with a uh
los angeles townhouse in it another
option is they're giving away the
lifeboats for free all you have to do is
prove if you can take them you should
put one of those in here yeah isn't it
haunted guys that's what went wrong on
the titanic just before they set sail
they offered to give the lifeboats away
to people for
uh
and a bunch of podcasters took them as a
gag
and they were like you sure you don't
need them no
this thing's unsinkable you think we're
gonna hit an iceberg
remember that specifically yeah i
remember this very well podcasts were
just getting started it was 1912
yeah
[Laughter]
they said hey free titanic lifeboat
giveaways
uh if and you can use them in your
podcast studio and then they set well
off we are to an for an uneventful
maiden voyage
they actually said that which was weird
yeah
the slogan was what could go wrong yeah
i think
anyway happy to be here and uh
mazeltov
i want to give a shout out to will
bechten uh eduardo perez uh and also uh
sarah federowicz has done so much to get
this going and of course our own erica
brown oh i mean and if i start
yeah eb gets it done yeah uh chris hayes
uh genius everybody's been working so
hard david cravelli yes oh my god oh my
god lighting team meyer's hume she's
giving them some love okay are we going
to really thank everybody well i just
want to also say blay
blay and beslow both get shout outs but
no also absolutely not [ __ ] me saying
that we should make it clear that this
is not even fully done so that if people
see this that they're not oh
no no it's going to get only better and
better and better